star trek picard keeps serving up easter
eggs for longtime trek fans from nods to
picard and worf's family histories to a
notable figure from the original series
it also has brent spiner playing yet
another character in a star trek show
here's all the references you may have
missed
in the fifth episode of season two we
finally learn more about what the crew
must do to get back to 2024 and the
reason for the divergence in the
timeline we learned that the woman
reading a dixon hill novel in the
previous episode wasn't just a random
passerby she's renee picard an important
thread in the tapestry of history and a
key figure in the family tree of
jean-luc picard she is the lead
astronaut for the upcoming europa
mission which we now know is more than a
simple easter egg referencing the series
fictional history of space flight it is
also a critical moment in the
development of earth toward their
brighter future renee picard also fits
in nicely to what we know of picard's
ancestors in the tng episode family we
met his brother and nephew and it was
said that picard's exploration of space
went against the family's tradition we
know from the episode journey's end that
he was descended from a 17th century
spanish soldier javier maribona picard
while a later picard fought for the
french at the battle of trafalgar in the
film star trek nemesis picard looked
back at his family history and noted
there weren't many picards who were
explorers he was one of the few who was
i was the first picard to leave our
solar system
it caused quite a stir in the family it
would seem that renee picard who shares
a first name with john luke's male
nephew renee seems to fit in perfectly
on the picard family tree while she is
apparently one of the rare explorers
that captain picard mentioned it seems
her exploration will be limited to our
own solar system
since arriving in the 21st century
picard and the crew of the la serena
have been seeking a mysterious being
called the watcher after gainan leads
picard to her doorstep were finally
introduced to a woman who somehow bears
the likeness of picard's romulan
companion larys but this is not lyris as
the watcher who introduces herself as
tallinn seems as mystified as we are by
the resemblance instead she describes
herself as a supervisor of earthly
events she has been assigned the task of
watching over historical events and
monitoring the destiny of renee picard
in particular who she describes as a
single thread of the tapestry of history
picard recognizes tallinn's
self-description right away recalling a
similar human who was once encountered
by kirk's enterprise
gary seven he too was recruited by
superior beings as an agent who would in
your words protect the tapestry of
history this is the season's second
reference to kirk's adventures on the
enterprise this time a nod to the
episode assignment earth the episode saw
kirk and crew travel back to 1968 where
they met a man called gary 7 who also
called himself supervisor tasked with
completing another agent's mission to
ensure that humans did not annihilate
each other in nuclear war with the
revelation of the watcher as one of gary
seven's people we now know that the
supervisors do more than just help
mankind on a broad historical level they
are also on earth to watch over and
protect important individuals whose
lives could impact the earth's destiny
we had heard that actor brent spiner
would be reappearing in season 2 even
before it began but some fans had
assumed that he would be reprising his
role from season 1 as alton in a gosun
the son of data's creator nunian tsum
instead he plays someone from much
earlier adam soon one of the scientists
ancestors
we saw a glimpse of him in the dark
future with a holographic monument to a
man named adam soon who preached that a
safe galaxy is a human galaxy now we
meet adam soon in the flesh who is not a
man far from the future but rather our
present in 2024 the ancestor of noon and
soon is a scientist and geneticist
apparently looking for a cure for his
daughter played by issa briones this
human daughter suffers from a rare
condition that makes sunlight fatal to
her in this episode sung is a leading
geneticist with delusions of curing all
of the world's diseases with his
research into eugenics this meshes with
the universe's fictional history
specifically the aftermath of the 1990s
eugenics wars this also tracks with what
we know of the zooms and like renee
picard adam soon fits perfectly within
the soon family tree on star trek
enterprise set less than 150 years into
adam soon's future his descendant
ericsson is a brilliant genetic
researcher a mad scientist who
genetically altered embryos to become
human super soldiers it would seem now
that the soon family's obsession with
improving humanity stretched further
back than we ever suspected ultimately
this soon has his medical license
revoked for a number of ethical
violations
adam soon's work in eugenics leads to a
number of important breakthroughs but it
hasn't been without its controversy
either having apparently experimented on
ex-soldiers through a private contractor
he's been brought before a medical
review board to explain himself among
the panelists however is a man with a
surname that fans of the next generation
should know well the dark-haired man
sits silently with a cold stare and his
name plate reads vasily regenco vice
chair this cannot be anything other than
an easter egg referencing tng's
lieutenant wharf the orphaned klingon
officer after being found by humans the
site of the kittimer massacre as a child
dwarf was raised by human foster parents
on earth a kind russian couple named
sergey and helena regenko
sergey of course appeared in the episode
family mostly a story about jean-luc
picard returning to france but in the b
story dwarf has a reunion with his earth
parents too we learned that sergey was
an enlisted starfleet crewman aboard the
uss intrepid and after marrying helena
they had one biological son nikolai who
was played by paul cervino in the
episode homeward later wharf's son
alexander would take the roshenko
surname as well little else was revealed
about the rajenko family on tng but here
we learn they have a rich family history
with vasily being an important figure in
the world's medical community in 2024
vasily roshenko wasn't the only easter
egg on the medical review board though
the panel's chairman is a woman named
diane werner and her appearance is a
clever nod to the series time travel
routes not just any guest star the woman
who plays werner is an actress with some
experience in time travel shenanigans
herself she also happens to be the woman
who directed the episode and the episode
prior leah thompson science fiction fans
will know the name from the 1980s time
travel trilogy back to the future where
thompson played marty mcfly's mother
lorraine mcfly
you know what i do in those situations
what
i don't worry
with episodes of star trek picard under
her belt she's re-entered the world of
science fiction on the other side of the
camera this time a perfect fit for the
woman who starred opposite michael j fox
in one of the most celebrated time
travel classics
now that picard has discovered the
watcher and learned just who and what
their mission to restore history
involves he gathers the lacirana crew to
go over a plan of action some including
rios are perplexed at how rene picard a
single woman could be so crucial to
history that she's the difference
between a bright and hopeful future and
a dark totalitarian nightmare reality
picard says he's not sure how or why his
ancestor is so important either but he
knows there's a reason why she's
apparently so unknown as he reminds the
crew the history of this time period is
wildly incomplete the century leading up
to first contact was just rife with
chaos and picard would know as this is a
clear reference to the events he took
part in during the film star trek first
contact another time travel story that
saw the enterprise go back to 2063 just
39 years after this episode is set in
that time it's said that the earth was
still recovering from the third world
war and most records of the era were
lost or incomplete here all picard
claims to know of his ancestor is that
she commanded the europa mission and
that while exploring the solar system it
was said that she discovered a
microorganism that she believed was
sentient clearly this is a hint of
things to come in the second half of
season two but if track history is
anything to go by it sounds like records
of the day will be lost during a major
global catastrophe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you